at on oublié croyez vous qu'il y ait de
pata peluche ne vous trompez pas notez
bien sur vos droits
moi d'abord parce qu'aucun attention il
en manque un
[Musique]
pas gentil et mare jeté mon sac des plus
purs derrière l'escalier et a passé une
super ambiance élevé plus sûres
[Musique]
ohlala je suis vraiment le plus
malheureux de pas passé un jour comme
aujourd'hui un jour où tout le monde
devra meeschaert le jour manas ne fait
pas
oui oui au sac à papier encore un ballon
dans les griffes où j'aurais très bien
pu me casser une jambe
c'était encore ceux ci n'apportent pas
ta suite à ta vie tu viens ici c'est la
wc bat asut anniversaire voie qui mène
un balado avoir été bon
pour l'amo et le tableau
on touche à combattre à 7,9 s attarder
bien vite on a besoin de toi allons
dépêche toi un peu
[Musique]
beney
ona
à faire
1 tu croyais qu'on avait oublié ton
anniversaire un one man mais
graduellement les voilà au tous les ans
voulait mais qui a pu faire ça moi j'ai
ma petite idée
monsieur bougon qu'est-ce que meneuse et
affine sa recette asus levage embrapa
c'est cadeau d'anniversaire ont disparu
et comme vous étiez furieux contre lui
tu ne t'es chez we cacher des cadeaux
bien mais je vais vous aider à les
retrouver alors toujours rien
mon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les patins plus je remonte chez moi
mikado métadonnées retrouvera ce fichu
ballon oui oui vous vous êtes fait mal
cette fois sous les cadeaux j'avais
confondu le sac des cadeaux avec celui
des épluchures et là qu'il avait sorti
de sa cachette mais oui pour mettre
développement autour des boîtes pour que
ce soit plus joli
pourquoi les oublier la tension s'est
tout de même moi qui les ai trouvés chez
cadeaux utiles bien-être c'est cadeau
bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de pas
taper je ne vous trompez pas
comptez bien sûr faux toi ô hasard dans
le cloud attention il en manque
[Musique]